langlis ne serait pas le fort de nos
étudiants médecine à tour nous sommes
allés vérifier auprès des premières
années un test simple traduire trois
phrase en anglais premier test BRI est
malade il doit aller chez le médecin il
doit aller chez le docteur
[Musique]
BR il paraît que les étudiants
médecinees sont très mauvais en
[Musique]
anglais
son médecin lui a donné une ordonnance
lui indiquant la dose de médicen pour sa
[Musique]
pathologie
médic
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la traduction littérale
mais on accepte des étudiants pas
toujours familiarisés avec la langue de
Shakespeare un tiers des deè années
aurait un niveau 6e un autre tiers un
niveau 3e insuffisant pour l'équipe
pédagogique qui est VO un handicap pour
nos futurs
médecins exerc un métier dans lequel
plus de 90% de et des références
internationales sont écrites en langue
anglaise où les grandes conférences
internationales sont uniquement en
langue anglaise et ou dans une un monde
dans lequel il y a de plus en plus
d'échanges si vous parlez pas anglais
vous pouvez pas communiquer avec ceses
patients ces futurs patients d'autant
plus qu'à partir de 2017 les examens en
6e année vont comporter une épreuve
d'analyse d'articles scientifiques en
anglais des articles qui ne seront plus
traduits en français parce que j'ai moi
j'habite en Angleterre donc j'ai un peu
perdu niveau d'anglais mais mais oui
franchement ça pourrait être pas mal moi
moi ça m'irait pas du tout bah l'écrit
encore ça vain comprend mais ilura
indispensable de de parler anglais je
pense pour faire des études de médecine
première année pour l'instant on a pas
de cours d'anglais aujourd'hui il faut
attendre la deuxème année pour avoir des
cours en anglais à la Faculté de
Médecine et encore ils sont optionnels
dès l'année prochaine les cours
d'anglais feront leur apparition dès la
première année et l'examen d'admission
c'est-à-dire la fin de cette première
année comportera désormais un test
anglophone sous forme de QCM mais
l'équipe pédagogique en est consciente
il sera impossible de faire des miracles